we're beginning with breaking news from
the u.s state of kentucky a grand jury
in louisville has indicted at least one
officer
involved in the killing of briona taylor
in march with wanton
endangerment two others are going to
face no
charges the city's mayor has declared a
72-hour curfew anticipating protests
taylor a black health worker was killed
at the age of 26 in a botched drug raid
though no drugs were found on the
property her name has become
a rallying cry in demonstrations against
police brutality
and racial injustice or kentucky's
attorney general daniel cameron speaking
live about the case
let's listen in kentucky law states that
a person is guilty of wanton
endangerment
in the first degree when under
circumstances manifesting in strength
indifference to the volume of human life
he wantly engages in conduct which
creates a substantial
danger of death or serious physical
injury to another person my office is
prepared to prove these charges
at trial however it's important to note
that he is presumed innocent
until proven guilty during the last six
months we've all heard mention of
possible charges
that could be brought in this case it's
important to understand
that all the charges that have been
mentioned have specific meanings
and ramifications criminal homicide
encompasses the taking of a life by
another
while there are six possible homicide
charges under kentucky law
these charges are not applicable to the
facts before us
because our investigation showed and the
grand jury agreed
that mattingly and cosgrove were
justified
in the return of deadly fire after
having been fired upon
by kenneth walker let me state that
again
according to kentucky law the use of
force by mattingly
and cosgrove was justified to protect
themselves
this justification bars us from pursuing
criminal charges
in ms brianna taylor's death
the truth is now before us the facts
have been
examined and a grand jury comprised of
our peers
and fellow citizens has made a decision
justice is not often easy does not fit
the mold of public opinion
and it does not conform to shifting
standards
it answers only to the facts and to the
law
with this in mind we must now ask
ourselves
where do we go from here will we
continue to prosecute
the charges brought in this case as it
now proceeds through the justice system
and moves to trial that is our
responsibility
and this will be done while the fbi
continues its investigation
into violations potential violations of
federal law
i know that not everyone will be
satisfied with the charges we've
reported today
my team set out to investigate the
circumstances surrounding
miss taylor's death we did it with a
singular
goal in mind pursuing the truth
kentuckians deserve no less
you're listening to kentucky attorney
general daniel cameron who's been giving
details of the judgment by the grand
jury in louisville
in the case of the killing of briana
taylor let's go to john hendren
live in louisville john the attorney
general there saying justice
does not fit the mold of public opinion
the big question of course now
is how people in louisville are going to
react to this
that's right you heard the attorney
general there say not everyone
will be pleased well i can tell you here
in louisville they're not
in a word we've heard people call those
charges that
single charge against one officer weak
we are here at the briana taylor
memorial this is a makeshift memorial
you can see
a picture of her black lives matter
signs
flowers and various tributes to her
these have been
up here in a kind of permanent protest
since this case began to get attention
weeks after the death of brianna taylor
and the reason it's here is that right
over there that
stone building is city hall that's where
the mayor is
um and then across from there is the
courthouse
that is not the courthouse where these
decisions were made today
and we have seen people here today who
have been
openly carrying arms now that's not
necessarily any kind of
threat here it's legally permissible as
we've seen at some of these other
protest sites
um but we do see people um
who have been carrying open weapons but
they have been
among the peaceful protesters the
suggestion is that that is all
in self-defense but the people we've
talked to out here have said that they
are very unhappy
with this decision it's one charge
against one officer
it is not a murder charge you heard the
attorney general there say that federal
officials are
still pursuing charges so there is the
possibility
for some kind of broader charges but
the idea of swat police breaking into
the home of someone who was not
the prime suspect and shooting her
dead in her own home as she lay in bed
has not
sat well with people here in louisville
and there is concern the police have
locked down
the whole central part of downtown
because
they are expecting there to be a
reaction there's a curfew
for three days that begins at nine
o'clock
each evening and i can tell you from the
other cities that we've been to
minneapolis
um kenosha wisconsin that people are not
likely
to abide by those curfews that's not how
the protests have operated here in the
u.s people are upset
we'll see in the coming hours how they
react and whether that
single charge will offer any mitigation
to the anger here in the streets yeah
john as you say that's absolutely the
key because the family of birona taylor
was
i think just a a week or so ago was
offered by the city a 12 million dollar
settlement and the city also pledged
that there were going to be reforms to
the police but from what you're saying
there's really a sense that
whatever the city is currently offering
it is not sound as though it's going to
be enough and people are going to be
expecting
more from the city
that's right i talked to brianna
taylor's mother uh
weeks ago here in louisville and
she said no amount of money could
compensate her
but the fact that the city has to pay 12
million dollars is a penalty
for them and now the concern
is how will there be reaction to the
streets if i'm going to ask my cameraman
to turn around because there are some of
those armed people that we've been
talking about
in black in the distance um
there are protests already scheduled as
far away as chicago a six-hour drive
from here for this
very evening so this is likely to be
another one of those incidents there was
a george floyd uh
in minneapolis jacob blake in kenosha
wisconsin and
we have had protests for beyonce brianna
taylor
here in louisville uh for months
this is likely to kick off more national
protests and they won't just be here
they will likely be
nationwide john thank you very much
indeed obviously as things progress
we're going to be checking back in with
you as time goes on but for now john
hendren in louisville thank you very
much indeed